what about uh teddy renair 10-time world
champ i think
two-time gold medalist at the olympics
two times bronze medalist at the
olympics
probably the most dominant judoka ever
is he in the running what do you think
about that guy
i think he's a a freak of nature teddy
you know if you look at the size just
how big he how tall he is how big he is
how physical he is of a specimen like i
sat next to him on a bus
and
like his legs are literally the size of
my waist yeah like when you sit next to
him and just look at the side he's a big
man
you know so
obviously to win 10 world titles in the
sport of judo i mean it that's uh that's
almost an incomprehensible feat uh
two-time olympic champion again
um
you know that puts him in one of the
maybe 10 or 12 people that ever do that
in the history of the sport so
he's definitely got to be in the running
for for the best but
you know technically i don't think he's
as technical as some of the other um
in terms of pure judo finance finesse
technique you know it's he's powerful
he's explosive he's dominant he's strong
um
teddy also grips really really well
which makes him
uh that much tougher to beat because a
lot of times heavyweights especially the
heavyweight division a lot of them just
grab the ghee and they go you know man
to man and judo to judo and take shots
at each other and that's why a lot of
them end up getting beat but teddy's in
control like positionally he stays in
really good position and he controls his
opponent the whole fight so they really
don't have a chance against them he
doesn't give them a chance to beat him
which is why he's been so dominant but
he's not really stalling so i mean he
does have a really nice
sort also
this uh
backward trip outside trip in case
people don't know i mean he has
just like technically pretty good throws
and for heavyweight yes heavyweights can
be sometimes messy
with their uh judo he's pretty
technical
and uh clean
in the execution of his big throws but
um a lot of that probably has to do with
the dominant gripping that he does it's
not defensive gripping it's offensive
gripping but the dominant gripping 100
he he controls the grips he controls the
movement of the match as a result of
that and then he creates his own
openings so i mean as a for a
heavyweight phenomenal technique yes um
and what you said messy i'd like to call
it sloppy right a lot a lot of the uh
heavy weights tend to be sloppy they've
fallen on the ground a lot
it's hard to move somebody that weighs
350 pounds you know it's hard to get
that body moving and just with the
simple uh pull motion so
um he's definitely found a way to do it
but he's also i don't know six foot
eight yeah you know he's probably weighs
140 kilos he's a big boy and but he had
this winning streak of just uh i don't
know how long but like over 100 matches
and he lost at this olympics that we
just went through the 20 i don't even
know what to call it 2021 olympics i
don't know the proper terminology tokyo
2020 okay 20. all right
so he lost to uh tamerlan bashev
i mean it's always sad to see a sort of
greatness come to an end it's like uh
corellon in wrestling and greco-roman
did you shed a bit of a tear to see
greatness go or um
like
or is it just the way of life
um i mean what did you think about sort
of this dominance this run of dominance
being stopped i think i mean it's
obviously sad to see i love seeing
champions succeed um especially people
that that are good people and i think
teddy's a good person you know i mean i
think there's some arrogant champions
that everybody would like to see lose
just because they don't want to deal
with their um you know their personality
or
but and i think but i think teddy's a
very humble champion you know he's a
people's champion you know he's
i think he's been privileged and he
makes good money from the sport of judo
and the french federation has taken care
of him well so he's a he's a lifelong
judo icon
so it's sad to see somebody like that
get beat especially when this could have
been you know his his third olympic
title and
um
you know just
become put him in infamy you know so it
was sad to see but i think you know
every athlete
goes through it right i mean you
it's just that's what the olympics is
all about the great ones fall sometimes
and um especially in judo right it's
like so
like the margin of error i mean i guess
the other question i want to ask here is
in your sense how difficult it is to not
lose for so long
it seems like in judo like a little
mistake
and it's over
there's no there's no coming back any
pawn means it's over so how difficult is
that is
it's hard to stay that dominant without
question first of all when you are when
you are the entire world is is training
against you just to be right they're
studying every single
movement they're they're studying
patterns they're they're trying to break
it down and find a flaw in your game
so everybody's hunting for you when
you're the best in the world especially
at the olympics that's that's the that's
the one to beat you at so
everybody's focused on you and then
there's an incredible amount of pressure
on that athlete to perform you know you
carry the flag for your country you know
when you're in opening ceremonies
sometimes you know there's all spotlight
is on you um
and it's particularly hard when things
don't go well early
you know in other words when you're
expected to win and then all of a sudden
now you're in a hard fight and it's not
going the way you want that pressure the
one who's the favorite feels the
pressure the most at the olympics and
that's why i think the other ones are
able to win it
i've actually never gotten a chance to
listen to teddy renair sort of explain
ideas behind his judo like i wonder what
his mental game is like because i think
his english is pretty not very good
and so
um and i just haven't seen good
interviews but it's always fascinating
to
there's certain great athletes that are
also great thinkers and speakers
like um the satire brothers in wrestling
again not meaning that that's on my
to-do list one hundred percent i'm going
to afghanistan and talking to them
because they're brilliant but to be able
to sort of um maybe after retirement to
to think back what were the systems
involved both on the technical
the training side
and then the uh mental side because like
to stay that dominant just like you're
saying everybody's studying to beat you
and
and the heavyweights are just these
powerful dudes
so to be able to control them with your
game and like the game that everybody
knows is coming is i don't know i don't
know what's behind that but there's got
to be um
it feels like the mental game is
exceptionally important
i think a lot of people underestimate
just how important that that side is
meant being mentally prepared for
victory mentally prepared to be the best
to stay the best um
there's nobody that's weak minded that
they can accomplish that you know it's
it's a hundred percent confidence and
belief in yourself
you